what's up theo schlong brendan schaub
i'm peter reporting to you live from
beautiful minneapolis minnesota
and i got a king of her sting it for you
uh this is my cat aggie
and i love her she's pretty cool to have
around but you know i'm a 23 year old
bachelor kind of navigating the dating
life here
and i found there's maybe a little bit
of a stigma with uh cat guys
yes so i'd love to hear cat's opinion on
this and everybody else is uh
king it or sting it mentioning being a
cat guy while dating uh thanks for
everything hope to see you guys soon
sometime in minneapolis and uh
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz my lonely
friend
yeah listen the loneliest friend listen
bro
ditch the [ __ ] cat there's nothing
worse man little man huge red flag no he
can't be having cats trying to get hoes
they don't mix up a cat no i never had a
cat see it was so
cats watch you have sex which is what i
don't like they always creep in the room
and it's like always weird you're like
what the [ __ ] is it
i hate cats me too oh yeah and that one
cat have you seen the one that's on the
internet and he's like
he's playing the piano and some [ __ ] cat
what do you think about
cats dudes and cats i can't date a guy
with a cat or a dog because i'm allergic
so either way it's a no-go for me
no damn is it a red flag if you're not
allergic though is it a red flag like
you came over like some dude's house he
had a bunch of
cats okay it depends on how many cats
you have and it depends on how you got
the cat if it's a family cat you've had
since childhood that's fine
if you're serious for no reason
oh she's specific about that wait what
about like a snake what if someone had a
snake yeah
if you repeat will you repeat that cat
the last part
the last part if you have three cats and
you're a single man who voluntarily
adopted them
there's something wrong yeah figure it
out dude i don't know what it is but you
have some sort of issue there and here's
the other thing you always gotta open up
those [ __ ] cans of the wet
food and dump it out it smells like [ __ ]
and another thing the cat's always
[ __ ] in the house and they just
cover it with gravel we act like it's
all good yeah you just leave this [ __ ]
and it's still fun yeah smells like [ __ ]
yeah i feel like a guy who voluntarily
has a lot of cats is a pushover because
cats are [ __ ]
yeah so you want like a [ __ ]
girlfriend yeah where
do you get a cat on my end what'd you
say cat i'm sorry
i said that wouldn't be terrible on my
end being somebody's [ __ ] girlfriend
yeah i could see you handling that
yeah you fit that role but dude yeah
cats will [ __ ] in your house and then
pretend that they did it man they're
just like uh
sigma news
jenna brings up a point though what
about like a snake all right what about
like all right
uh reptiles and [ __ ] we're doing the rat
king video he also has
gone theo has reptile he has reptile
dysfunction as well
yeah these are all red flags that you're
a lonely ass dude if you got a snake and
a [ __ ] he's got
lizard and [ __ ] when we were doing those
rat king videos he we were like we need
rats and theo's like call ari we called
ari he came in with like these big rats
this big he's like oh yeah i feed these
to my snake
yup he had a website 30minuterats.com
but yeah cat would you date someone with
a snake it depends on what type of snake
if it's big enough and you're feeding it
multiple dead rats i can't [ __ ] with you
because i don't like the idea of
somebody having a rat smashing it
against a wall and feeding it to the
snake every week
what a stupid-ass animal snake yeah i
mean you can't
what do you do with the [ __ ] thing
yeah you take it out you look at dude
yeah very cool you put it back in the
tank yeah that's what we do
we used to have a kid in our
neighborhood he would get little rat
little mice or whatever and he would
make
nooses and actually hang them and then
feed the snake
that kid's a [ __ ] psychopath
[Laughter]
and he's sheriff now he's sheriff
well he grew up i guess right well she
got nick yeah man
hey people change man
[Music]
is